if anybody's worth it it's it's you so
I'm gonna try my best to be real and
develop something real
former Bachelorette contestant Tyler G
has died at the age of 29 the Boca Raton
PD confirms to ET that they responded to
a medical overdose involving Tyler he
has confirmed that Tyler's body is with
the Palm Beach County Medical Examiner's
Office and the case is an active ongoing
investigation the Batchelor producers
released a statement on Tyler's passing
saying quote we are heartbroken to hear
the tragic news of Tyler's passing today
adding their thoughts are with his
family and friends
Tyler G was on Hannah Brown season and
got the first one-on-one date the day
card red falling in love can be messy
and I have no idea
what we're doing today but I'm here to
find love with him he just was really
calming and nurturing for me to feel
confident going into these one-on-ones
but he mysteriously left the show one
week after in an email to refinery29
Tyler said it was the best decision that
he could have made the Bachelorette alum
also said that the reason for his
departure wasn't aired in order to
respect his privacy